WE ARE GOING TO GET RIGHT TO IT.
AMERICA SHRINKING WITH BLINKING.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
ONE OF THE BIG QUESTION MARKS OF
LAST YEARS HAS BEEN WHO WILL BE
ACTUALLY RUNNING THE SHOW IN ANY
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
OBVIOUSLY, BIDEN HIMSELF CANNOT
CARRY THE BURDEN OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
HE CAN EVEN GET THROUGH A
WEEKEND WITH HIS DOGS.
SOMEONE HAS TO CALL THE SHOTS.
IT IS NOW OBVIOUS THAT ON THE
THREE TOPICS OF FOREIGN POLICY,
TRADE POLICY, AND CHINA THERE IS
A BOLD NEW CORES -- THE REAL
POWER AND IF BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE TONY
BLINKEN.
>> HOW WILL JOE BIDEN AS AS A
PRESIDENT VIEW CHINA, PARTNER,
COMPETITOR, RIVAL, ENEMY, WHAT
AND HOW QUESTION MEXICO SOME
COMBINATION OF ALL YOU JUST
SAID.
>> Laura: HOW PROFOUND.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT, FIRST
BIDEN SAYS CHINA IS NOT A
THREAT.
THEN HIS ECHO TERRY STATE SAYS
THEY ARE ALMOST PARTNERS WITH
US?
WHAT’S NEXT, THEY HELP DECORATE
THE WHITE HOUSE CHRISTMAS TREE
NEXT YEAR?
WHAT ARE BLINKING BLINKEN’S PLAN
THE NOTION THAT AMERICA MUST
NEVER, EVER DO ANYTHING ON ITS
OWN.
HERE’S A QUOTE FROM BLINKEN.
WE ARE NOT THE LEADER OF FIRST
CHOICE BECAUSE WE ARE ALWAYS
RIGHT OR BECAUSE WE ARE
UNIVERSALLY LIKED, IT IS BECAUSE
WE CAN STRIVE WITH THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY TO OUR LINEUP OUR
ACTIONS WITH THE PRINCIPLES AND
BECAUSE OUR LEADERSHIP HAS THE
ABILITY TO MOBILIZE OTHERS AND
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
LET’S LOOK AT THIS QUOTE
CAREFULLY.
IT THE FIRST ASSURES US THAT THE
POWER DOESN’T COME FROM THE
RIGHTEOUSNESS OF ITS CAUSE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WASHINGTON OR
LINCOLN OR FDR OR REAGAN, OR
TRUMP TALKING ABOUT AMERICA IN
SUCH A DISMISSIVE WAY?
SO FAR SO BAD.
IT DOES ECHO ONE OF HER PREVIOUS
LEADERS.
IT’S BECAUSE THERE’VE BEEN TIMES
WHERE AMERICA HAS SHOWED
ARROGANCE AND BEEN DISMISSIVE.
EVEN DERISIVE.
>> AMERICANS ARE NOT YOUR ENEMY.
WE SOMETIMES MAKE MISTAKES, WE
HAVE NOT BEEN PERFECT.
WE HAVE MADE OUR SHARE OF
MISTAKES FROM RESTORATION.
>> OF AMERICA’S STANDING IN THE
WORLD.
THE AMERICANS ARE WORKING
THROUGH OUR OWN DARKER.
MAX AND HER HISTORY.
>> Laura: THE THE BIDEN DARK
WINTER IS JUST STARTING.
WHAT DOES MR. BLINKEN SEE IS
AMERICA’S STRENGTH?
WE STRIVE TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITIES TO ALIGN YOUR ACTIONS
WITH THEIR PRINCIPLES.
THAT STATEMENT IS JUST
MEANINGLESS SPEAK.
EVERY GOVERNMENT SEEKS TO
ENLIVEN ITS ACTIONS WITH ITS
PRINCIPLES.
PRESIDENT XI DOES IT IN CHINA.
SO DOES MAYER MAYOR de BLASIO AN
DUMBLEDORE AT HOGWARTS.
THE ONLY REAL ONE ACCORDING TO
BLINKEN’S QUOTE IS THAT OUR
LEADERSHIP HOLDS THE ABILITY TO
MOBILIZE OTHERS AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
ACCORDING TO HIM, AMERICA ACTING
ALONE COUNTS FOR NOTHING.
WE ARE ONLY IMPORTANT IF WE CAN
MOBILIZE OTHERS.
WE DIDN’T WIN THE COLD WAR WITH
TROOPS OR MONEY, WE SIMPLY
MOBILIZED OTHERS.
THE PROTESTERS IN HONG KONG THIS
SUMMER, THEY DID NOT WAIVE
AMERICAN FLAGS BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVED IN OUR IDEAL OF FREEDOM
FREEDOM, THEY WERE JUSUST HAPPY
HAVE OTHER COUNTRIES ON SPEED
DIAL, APPARENTLY.
WHAT IF OTHER COUNTRIES REFUSED
TO BE MOBILIZED?
WHAT IF HEAVEN FORBID THEY PUT
THEIR INTERESTS AHEAD OF OURS?
>> FOR DECADES, THE SAME TIRED
OF VOICES PROPOSED THE SAME
FAILED SOLUTIONS.
A PURSUING GLOBAL AMBITIONS AT
THE EXPENSE OF THEIR OWN PEOPLE,
BUT ONLY WHEN YOU TAKE CARE OF
YOUR OWN CITIZENS WILL YOU FIND
A TRUE BASIS FOR COOPERATION.
>> Laura: FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT IF
MR. BLINKEN ASKED THE EUROPEANS
FOR HELP ON CHINA, AND THEY SAY
NO?
WHAT IF HE ASKED THEM TO PUT
PRESSURE ON IRAN, AND THEY
REFUSE?
WELL I GUESS HE’S OUT OF OPTIONS
BECAUSE HIS ONLY POWER, THE
POWER TO MOBILIZE OTHERS, WON’T
ALWAYS WORK.
BLINKEN IS ESSENTIALLY
ANNOUNCING TO THE WORLD THAT WE
WILL NEVER ACT UNILATERALLY.
WE WILL DEPEND ON THE GOODWILL
OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
THIS IS BEEN TRIED BEFORE.
>> AMERICA CAN’T DO THIS ALONE.
THE AFGHAN PEOPLE NEED OUR
TROOPS AND YOUR TROOPS.
OUR SUPPORT AND YOUR SUPPORT.
>> THE FUTURE THAT WE ARE
BUILDING TOGETHER, NOT
SEPARATELY.
AT THAT STARTS HERE IN EUROPE.
THE PEOPLE OF EUROPE ARE MORE
SECURE AND MORE PROSPEROUS
BECAUSE WE STOOD TOGETHER FOR
THE IDEALS WE SHARE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
THE EUROPEANS HELPED OBAMA IN
SUCH LOW ESTEEM THAT THEY DIDN’T
DO ANYTHING OF SIGNIFICANCE TO
HELP WITH CHINA.
JAPANESE AND OTHER ASIAN
COUNTRIES SIGNED THE PACIFIC
PARTNERSHIP.
THAT DEAL WAS SO BAD FOR YOU DID
BAD FOR UNITED STATES AND SO
FAVORABLE TO OTHER COUNTRIES,
EVEN HILLARY CLINTON HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO OPPOSE IT.
ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY THAT EVERYONE KNOWS HOW
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A SUCKER.
SO WHEN BLINKEN TRIES TO
MOBILIZE THE E.U. AGAINST CHINA,
HE WILL HAVE TO SACRIFICE OUR
TRADE POLICY TO PLEASE YOU YOUR
CATS AT THE WTO TO EVEN GET A
HEARING.
IF HE WILL TRADE AMERICAN JOBS
BY LIMITING THE TARIFFS PUT IN
PLACE BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> DOES TRUMP HAVE A POINT THAT
THERE IS A SYSTEMATIC SET OF
PREDATORY PRACTICES THAT
EUROPEANS HAVE ENACTED?
>> HE HAS A POINT ON SPECIFIC
PRODUCTS AND INDUSTRIES, BUT
STARTING A TRADE WAR WITH OUR
CLOSEST ALLIES IS NOT THE WAY TO
MAKE THAT POINT.
HE HAS NOW STARTED A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
>> Laura: BLINKEN WILL PUT
ISRAEL AND THE ENTIRE MIDDLE
EAST AT RISK BY DOING WHAT
EUROPE WANTS.
THEY ARE GIVING A FREE HAND IN
SOME MAD MONEY.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION NUCLEAR
DEAL THAT TRUMP LITTLE US OUT
OF.
>> IT’S MADE A SAFER COME UP
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
SAFER.
A PART OF THAT INVOLVES LIFTING
SANCTIONS ON IRAN.
THAT FREED UP MONEY THAT T WAS
FROZEN AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY HAD A BANK ACCOUNT.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THAT MONEY IS GOING INTO THE
ECONOMY.
>> Laura: A BLINKEN KNOWS, HOW
DARE YOU QUESTION HIM?
CHINA, BLINKEN WILL GET A HERO’S
WELCOME IN BEIJING.
>> HE WON’T BE IN TOUGH AS CHINA
AS TRUMPETS BEEN.
HE HAS TRIED TO DESTROY CHINA IN
THIS WAY.
>> IT’S GOOD FOR THE WORLD THAT
BIDEN HAS ONE.
>> BIDEN AND HIS GLOBALIST
LACKEYS WILL POUR NEW
INVESTMENTS INTO CHINA,
ENERGIZING ITS EFFORTS TO BECOME
THE MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY
ON EARTH.
AS CHINA GETS STRONGER AND WE
GET WEAKER, WE MUST MAKE
BLINKEN’S PEACE THROUGH
SURRENDER POLICY A MAJOR ISSUE
GOING FORWARD, INCLUDING IN THE
GEORGIA SENATE RACE.
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE
OF GEORGIA WANT TO GIVE UP ON
AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY AND TO
LEAVE THEMSELVES WHOLLY
DEPENDENT ON THE GOODWILL OF THE
EUROPEANS, THE CANADIANS, OR ANY
OTHER COUNTRY FOR THAT MATTER.
THE CONFIRMATION HEARING FOR
BLINKEN MUST FEATURE SHARP AND
FOCUSED QUESTIONING FROM
REPUBLICANS WHO CHALLENGE HIS
FALL OF THE WORLD FOREIGN
POLICY.
AND AS THE INEVITABLE RESULT OF
THE BIDEN APPROACH MANIFEST, WE
CAN GO BACK TO THE COUNTRY,
LET’S SAY IN 2022, 2024, AND
SEEK A RETURN TO COMMON SENSE